hey youtubers it's Charlie and during my
Walking Dead review this week I asked
you to submit all of your questions
about the WTF s that went down so I
picked 10 of them to answer in this
video with one bonus question All Things
Considered everyone was pretty much on
the same page as far as Lizzy went but
everyone seems to want to talk about
what's coming next before we get into it
quick shout out to this week's giveaway
winner congratulations to Becky green
you win a $20 Amazon gift card I'll be
reaching out to you on your channel for
details but everyone be sure to give her
a high five
yay don't worry if you didn't win the
next round of the giveaway starts on
Sunday and for the finale two weeks from
now I'll be doubling down and giving
away two gift cards I'm also doing the
exact same thing whenever Game of
Thrones comes around - so there's
basically gonna be like three straight
months of weekly giveaways so on to fun
time let's answer some questions number
one comes from dekappa soros ouch that
sounds like it hurts who asks based on
these two deaths do you think that
there's going to be another major death
before the season ends so yes based on
all the rumors everything we've learned
even the super crazy rumors I think that
something else is coming it seems like
they're still building towards one more
death to launch things in the season 5 a
lot of people are pointing fingers at
Daryl based on the teaser for the next
episode he isn't integrating well into
that roving band of lunatics and they're
making fun of the fact that he can't
find Beth I think that's just
misdirection though but I'm not gonna
call them hunters or you know something
worse until I see human flesh go down
someone's throat that doesn't mean that
once everyone gets determinist though
they won't be responsible for whoever
dies next they are a pretty terrible
group my earlier prediction about the
death was Maggie just since it fit with
some of the more logical rumors to be
honest there's no character that I love
so badly over the others that I would
freak out if they died so no matter what
we are going to feel awful based on
everything I've heard about the actual
finale at least the tone of the finale
is that it's not going to be nearly as
bad as the season 3 finale they're not
gonna do a repeat that I'm just gonna do
the exact same thing question number 2
Kaos device asks do you think that the
fire was from the house that Beth and
Daryl lit up absolutely and it did not
look like it was that far away they saw
it during the day so this episode
probably took place the day after
episode 12
so all this Lizzie business was going
down Daryl was in the process of getting
separated from Beth
question number three mikado tanaka asks
do you think the Grove will be haunted
by the spirits of Lizzie and mica from
now on I'm assuming that based on your
question you do believe that ghosts
exist so let's assume they do exist and
are capable of perpetrating said
hauntings by that logic yes they are
totally haunting the Grove with that
little other kid that died before they
got there at least there's three of them
now consequently though in most horror
movies ghosts haunt places because they
can't move forward that means that
Lizzie is still totally crazy and mica
is stuck with her for the rest of time
does that mean that mica is stuck in
hell I'll let you guys answer that
question my alternate theory is that
they're following Carol around and
they're gonna give her nightmares just
like Karen gives Tyreese question number
four rasengan asks when do you think
that negan will show up so Robert
Kirkman was pretty clear on wanting a
lot of space between the governor and
negan so I think it's gonna be at least
midway through season five before [ __ ]
never becomes a recurring character
maybe even later than that I am
expecting some teasers in the finale I'm
thinking that someone at terminus might
refer to the Savior's which really is a
negan teaser because we haven't met
Gareth yet though it's pretty clear that
he's going to be the big character we're
gonna be at terminus for better or worse
he's supposed to be an antagonist but if
he's an amalgam of Gabriel and Jesus
then he's a good person both of those
characters actually help the survivor so
it's really unclear if there's going to
be an actual villain at terminus or if
it's just gonna be a new character
question number five Sandra and six six
nine zero asks why did Lizzie kill her
sister so remember when Lizzie was on
the train tracks and she said I'll
change myself and then you'll understand
she was talking about making Myka
understand that the walkers were people
she thought of them the way we would
think about our best friends and not as
slowly moving by T heads I think she
thought the best way you know to quote
unquote show Myka was to turn her which
is why she said don't worry she'll come
back I didn't hurt her brain because
hurting the brain is the only way to
kill a walker and on top of all that she
was going to turn Judith to make Carol
and Tyreese understand thank God that
she did not question number six D 95
part 4 asks
since Darrell was shown in the trailer
after the episode do you think that
we'll find out what happened to Beth
next week
so it seemed like everyone was in the
teaser but Beth so I kind of think that
they're holding that off for the finale
it makes a weird kind of sense for the
writers to hang Beth over our heads so
to speak
you know for one more week just making
us wonder who kidnapped her and whether
or not she's alive had those things to
the awfulness that looks like it's going
to be happening anyway and you arrived
at the stress level AMC wants you to be
at the way I look at it is that they
want everyone in the world to watch that
finale and the best way to get you to do
that is to hold off on some of the big
questions namely in this case revealing
what happened to Beth I think the other
big question we need to ask is is what
is the footage that's going to be in the
teaser for the actual finale during
episode 15 question number 7 t baby 0 4
8 6 asks how do you think that Rick will
handle seeing Carol again will Tyreese
vouch for her because of the things she
had to do and how about Daryl if he
comes back how will he react to Carol
now so Rick will probably mostly just be
happy to see Judith again so he's gonna
forget about any bad blood between him
and Carol and really Carol was not
pissed whenever they parted ways so they
don't hate each other and even if they
did Rick is probably just happy to find
more familiar faces that survived the
governor's attack he's a pretty broken
man right now yes there will probably be
an awkward pause whenever they first see
each other you know until the camera
pans to Judith and then everyone will
just break down crying tears of joy and
really I think the same thing would
happen if Daryl runs into Carol like he
would just be so happy to see her he
wouldn't care about anything else
question number 8 Jaime Lannister asks
do you think they should have left Lizzy
alone with all her friends I assume
you're talking about after she killed
Mika I think they didn't just because
Carol and Tyreese still felt really
responsible for her especially Carol and
even if they did try to abandon her
Lizzie just would have followed them I
think you know had they tied her up to a
tree or something like that it would
have just been cruel and as much as Mika
talked about not wanting to be bad fan
Carol killing Lizzie I don't think the
Carol has ever been a bad person
she is a little extreme but remember
whenever she confessed to Rick she said
there's nothing that she would not do
for the children question number 9 Ben
Joffrey asks do you think the Carol will
eventually kill herself with the shame
of the murders fresh on her hands
so at this point on the show I consider
Carol to be so different from the comic
book version of her character that it's
not even close there are so many plot
points that happen differently and
psychologically I think Melissa
McBride's version is much more in
control of herself she's like the
opposite of helpless and sometimes
whenever people do commit suicide it's
because they feel helpless had she
considered it for a moment
I think the tyreese's speech about doing
what they have to do and continuing on
shook her out of it all that considered
she will definitely be having nightmares
about those children for the rest of her
life question number 10 Chiara Ortiz
asks which groups do you think are going
to be reunited first so in the teaser we
saw Daryl Abraham's group and Rick's
group so they're all moving towards
terminus at about the same rate Glen is
the furthest behind so I do think that
they'll run into Rick's group first most
of the time but not always the people we
see in the teasers are the only groups
that the episodes have been focusing on
so it's possible that Carol and Tyreese
as well as Beth won't show up to the
finale so I'm just excluding them from
this and since Daryl's group is moving
all over the place it's also possible
that he could stumble upon Abraham and
Rick himself first it kind of seems like
Daryl's gonna have a tough time quitting
that group so it might take some of the
other survivors you know like Abraham
and his muscles to help get rid of Joe
and the rednecks and one last bonus
question
Natalie Ellis asks do you think that
Rick will ever be killed off so this is
actually a really big problem for Robert
Kirkman in the comic books right now
this is big conflict going on called
all-out war I think that Kirkman wants
to be able to safely kill off Rick at
some point you know without completely
alienating the fandom but as a temporary
way to kind of decide step the issue
they've started to feature a different
group that does not include Rick just to
take the heat off the issue you know so
to speak so short answer whatever
happens to him will probably happen in
the comics first unless Andrew Lincoln
the actor wants off the show
it doesn't always follow the comic but
for the people that are alive especially
this season all the deaths have gone
down pretty closely to the way they
happen in the comics so thank you so
much for submitting your questions this
is a lot of fun as always one more high
five to Becky for winning this week's
giveaway a lot of you have started to
ask me to do season 5 videos you know
Duke
predictions for what's gonna happen next
season I'm going to be doing all of
those kind of videos but I'm just wait
until we get a little bit closer to the
finale there's still so much we don't
know about how this season's gonna end
in other news tomorrow is marvel Tuesday
and supposedly we're getting new
Avengers 2 footage so get excited for
that in the meantime though click here
to watch my review of the episode and
click here to get the rest of my season
4 predictions a couple of them have
already come true in this episode you
know this stuff right here but there's
still a ton of stuff left to happen so
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you guys tomorrow
high fives